[Applause]
thank you okay we will start with number
211.
Germany
um
so can you put into words what it's like
to win an Oscar and where are you going
to party tonight and do you want to have
that in German or in English in German
would be better okay
um
foreign
next up we have number two on Five can
you hold your number up high so we can
get a microphone over to you
hi there congratulations the score is
absolutely chilling unhinged it's so
memorable tell us what your great
grandmother would think about you
winning an Oscar now and about your
great grandmother's harmonium and how it
played a role well why we while we were
driving here we were thinking if she
would have been amazed if she would see
what her instrument was was doing yeah
um well when I was starting looking at
these Throne three notes theme that I
that is you know the a lot of the times
the theme that is presented
um I was thinking about you know an
instrument from that time
um in um because the war was in 1918 so
I was thinking what instrument could
that be and on my way to the studio I
was thinking I have this harmonium of my
grand grandmother in the studio that I
refurbished
so I was using that as the as the
instrument that is doing this three note
Motif and I miked it up with eight
microphones so I'm normally you delete
all the noises in the you know when you
record an instrument but I actually
recorded all the the woods the wind
inside the the breathing of the
instrument
um and I distorted it and I just
played it through an amplifier like a
guitar like a rock guitar amplifier and
that's mainly it what the um the theme
was
my grand grandmother would maybe think
at the when I'm using the amplifier she
would maybe not go with me because uh
you know they were mostly playing with
this instrument Christian songs in their
homes
so the amplifier would always be a
little bit too raw I would say yes
thank you next time we have number three
by the last last question from three six
oh
so three three six please and just a
friendly reminder if you do ask your
question in a language other than
English if you can repeat it in English
afterwards so the rest yeah Stan that
would be wonderful sorry about that oh
no no
yeah yeah absolutely so congratulations
agency I ask you an you in English but
if you can answer in German
um you were nominated five years ago for
lion a very different movie very
different music what did it mean to you
to make
now the soundtrack for the sound for a
movie that is a war movie
um with a lot of history in Germany well
I mean making music for a war movie
means I repeat that in German I'll do
first English
um making music for a war movie is very
difficult because in a way when you just
cross the line of Music a little bit too
too much you suddenly create a lot of
Pathos in a war movie and suddenly
everybody who had holds a gun is
suddenly a hero or is suddenly you know
is in a different shown in it in a
different light so I wanted to find a
way of letting the people judge what the
the viewers of Judge what they think
about the acting and the acting is
fantastic so that helped a lot because a
lot of times as a musician you have to
cover certain weaknesses in in you know
in the acting or in the in the film
itself and in this case I wanted to just
be very delicate with the music and you
know using places where the music can
also be presented very loud so Edward
was saying it has to be at some point we
just we have to blast it in a way and uh
so I've I tried to find places like that
so I will repeat that in June if I can
um
of European Creekstone
delicators and they are um
and then final question
questions
can you explain the success is it in
German it's under subtitled it's
um German but the music is international
what is the reason for this incredible
success because it's a great film and it
has a long it has a long you need a you
need for a for a kind of long path of a
film
you know over like from Toronto Film
Festival until now you need a lot of
breath
to push a film like that and if it's a
good film you don't need to push so hard
you can actually have a good timing for
you know
presenting it at a certain moments and I
think if it would be a bad film we would
be already not here
thank you
all right wonderful thank you so much
and congratulations under Oscars
thank you very much